squash
[Music]
so
on hello
i'm on
good evening hello
hi thanks brett
welcome to the table my name is karen
miner i'm so glad that you're all here
tonight
in the middle of summer i have a few
announcements
uh first of all oh gosh everybody's
streaming in come on in
find a seat good to see you that's okay
we're all family here some family
members are late some are on time you
know
[Laughter]
yeah so announcements i've got
three of them so i thought we would just
jump in
the first one is immediately after the
service tonight we're going to head over
to hat creek burger company
in saxi yeah we like to get together
as a church community once a month
usually it's the first sunday
but last week was fourth of july so we
pushed it to this sunday so immediately
after the service
head over there we'll meet on the patio
great food great people you can get to
know
get to know the church a little bit
better uh our hosts for tonight
scott raise your hand scott's back there
on sound and his wife brittany who is
our kids oh you're here
yay this is a moment
i never see brittany in the service so
i'm so glad you're here too
um brittany and scott will be the host
so when you head over there to hat creek
just look for them and they'll get
tables together and make sure you have a
place to sit
and someone to talk to so uh
secondly i would like to have our event
planner for the table miranda
come up uh yay
yay and just give an update on
uh one of our one of our events that we
had
yeah so i think it was back in april
whenever we had the clothing drive so
it's been a while
we donated a bunch of clothes to a
company called
trusted world and they're based in
garland and
what they kind of do is they work with
schools agencies and non-profits around
the world basically to provide
food clothes and hygiene care for people
and they actually work with five loaves
which we work with so that's kind of
cool
we were able to donate about 13 bags of
clothes to them
and they were very excited and grateful
to receive them whenever we went there
and they were like we're ready for
volunteers so bring them over
so hopefully we can work with them in
the coming months nice
cool thank you thanks miranda it's good
to hear
kind of how things turn out you know we
i know we announced the clothing drive
and a lot of you participated in
bringing clothes and things like that
and it's
it's good to circle back around and hear
how did that go and to hear about the
connections that are being made in the
community so thank you
and now that things are opening up a
little bit more with kovid
we are going to have more events
happening so miranda thank you
for being willing to head those things
up and speaking of events
august 8th please save the date we
are going to have an outdoor church
service celebration from four to seven
p.m
at the tilford rental home in saxi
and we're going to do baptisms it's
going to be great um
this is our first round of table baptism
so you can actually make history
by getting baptized that sunday
so if you are interested in baptism if
you're like what even
is baptism i'm not quite sure um or if
it's been a long time since you've been
baptized maybe
god's been working in your heart in a
new way lately and you want to
take that step again uh we're going to
have some information about baptism so
what you need to do to get in on that
is back right by the back door that you
most all of you walked into there's a
box there are cards
please put your name and your contact
information and brett will get in
contact with you with information about
baptism
so we're really looking forward to that
gathering it will take the place of our
5 pm service here so we'll just be
outside there will be
food baptisms a pool it's going to be
really fun so i hope you all
can make it i think that's it i think i
got all the announcements
some nights there's there's a few more
than others but um
if you don't hear anything else please
just hear that
we love you guys we're so glad you're
here
uh i don't think it's an accident that
you're in this room or watching online
tonight we're getting ready to embark on
a new series on deconstruction
i can't wait for it it's gonna be great
so how about before we jump into worship
with these lovely people behind me
let's prepare our hearts and our minds
for worship with prayer
god thank you for today
and all the ways that you're in it all
the ways that you are with us
and working in our hearts and our minds
and god thank you that you
are good thank you that you are love
and we can never outrun that love we can
never out question
or out doubt that love
god you are a firm foundation and
your word says that when we seek when we
ask we find you so god help us to be
curious
tonight help us to seek you to fix our
minds and our hearts on you
and that we would find you so we give
this time to you
and we thank you god for what you're
doing in our lives and our hearts and
among our community
in jesus name amen
amen thanks karen well if you guys feel
comfortable standing with us we're going
to spend a little bit of time
singing together and i know we have
these
fancy walls right here but if it was
my ideal situation we would be
around my living room or a campfire
or something very informal all
singing in a circle together so if you
can kind of in your mind try to separate
this wall that separates the stage from
the chairs
and just imagine that this is a chance
for us to come together as a community
and say words that we believe are true
about a god who is with us and for us
that's what worship is that's the
opportunity that we have
in front of us and whether you're on the
stage or in those chairs
your worship is heard and he is close to
us
and um we just want to do this part of
our service
in a communal together way so
um i just invite you into that space
caitlyn's going to lead our first
song so let's go ahead and get started
come and tear down the walls i built up
every wall i built up every wall i built
up
cause you deserve every piece of my
heart
every piece of my heart every piece of
my heart
lord i am trusting that you
are a faithful father and
all that you have it is like no
[Music]
over and over and over again
my
[Music]
i am trusting that you are a faithful
it is father you're a generous
giver your love's like no other
won't you come and break through to me
over and over and over again
i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands closer and closer you're
drawing me in
as the depths of my heart
[Music]
over and over and over
again i am bringing my heart to you
with open hands
[Music]
again
my heart
come and tear down the walls i've built
up every wall i've built up
every wall i've built up
cause you deserve every piece of my
heart
every piece of my heart every piece in
my heart one more time
come and tear down
[Music]
cause you deserve every piece of my
heart
every piece of my
[Music]
yes thank you god we're going to
enter into a prayer of the people now
and if this this is your first time
with us um this is a tradition
in christian history that's been carried
on for
a really long time so we're just kind of
joining in
um to a larger tradition here
and i'm going to say a short prayer to
get us started
and then i'm going to leave some space
for us to
list out um names of people who might be
on your heart or situations going on
in the world around us that you are
burdened by or that you've been carrying
that you are concerned about and this is
really an opportunity for us to just
hold them up in prayer together before
god believing that he's listening
and that he is a god that cares for us
and that he's close to the brokenhearted
and um we want to carry each other's
burdens
we want to bear with one another and be
there for each other as a community
so as you list out names we just welcome
you even if you're online
to type in a name and karen will be
watching that and
let's just hold those up together and
trust that god
is with us in that and then when we
finish i will
close us out with another short prayer
and we'll move on
into the rest of our worship set
i forgot to mention that i think the
prayer is going to be up on the screen
and at the end of each line of the
prayer in red i believe there's a phrase
we pray to you and if you guys want to
join in with me as i say that part
it just gives us an opportunity to kind
of agree together
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you for the good earth that
you have given us
and the wisdom and will to conserve it
we pray to you for those
who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for
all of those who remember and care for
them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us
and that you hear us and so now we lift
these names and situations
up to you
from online gabriel kathy
sarah johnny owen
for the oppressed
[Music]
right
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud
and for those that we have kept in our
hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
and healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
amen
come to the river
all who are thirsty
come and drink
come to the table
all who are hungry
come and feast
those who are weary
those who are needy
come received
come to the river
taste and see
come to the water
come to the table
all who are hungry
those who are needy
come to the river
taste and see
[Music]
hey
let's sing o my soul my
[Music]
soul
you
[Music]
and
and i will taste
and see that you are good
i will taste
and see that you are good to me
[Music]
and see that you are good
i will take
and see that you are good you're good to
me
single my soul oh my
soul
[Music]
oh my
soul
[Music]
who are thirsty
come and dream
[Music]
come to the table
peace
yes jesus thank you that you are always
there and available and ready to feed us
to nurture us to love on us
thank you for your love that is ever
present
and unconditional
and god help us to connect with that
love tonight
it's the first time i've sung
back since covet started with hearing
all these voices it's just absolutely
beautiful hearing all your voices
this is awesome
[Music]
you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song you are beautiful
my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song i will sing again
you are so good to me you heal my broken
heart
you are my father in heaven
you are so good to me you hear my broken
heart
you are my father in heaven
you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song you are beautiful
my sweet sweet song
you're around
lead me to truth you want the spirit
inside me you are
beautiful my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song you are beautiful
my sweet sweet song i will sing again
[Music]
see
you poured out all your blood you died
upon the cross
you are love jesus
[Music]
you are my
you are jesus my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet sweet
[Music]
you are beautiful
you are
[Music]
you beautiful beautiful my sweet sweet
soul
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
you you are beautiful my sweet sweet
song
[Music]
yes thank you god for this time together
we worship you and we pray god that you
would be close to us and open our hearts
to what you have
for tonight and it's in your name i pray
amen
all right you guys brett's gonna come up
and share with us
why don't we turn to each other and the
people around you and say hello as he
does
evening there we go there i'm on hello
everybody you doing well doing good
awesome awesome awesome um
well it is great to be back it's been uh
some of you don't know but i took
um some time off in in june
um and just i just needed break it's
been quite the few years for those who
know our story
it's been quite the few years and uh so
i just need a little rest
and um so we took some that space and um
it was really really wonderful
um actually i want to show you we have a
few pictures and things of like some
vacations things we did but before i do
that i also want to welcome those join
us online
i love you all you are not forgotten um
thank you for being with us as well so
um i think we have some some images yeah
so
here we had a lot of trips so i did
um kind of a family reunion with um
on maggie's uh kind of side that family
so we did that
um and then um
we did um oh what's the second one
too many trips oh our anniversary our
little get a little get away
that's you don't forget that one no it
was the other one that's the one i
forgot about
um so yeah so we did that was it was so
great although we stated uh
basically we just went on group and
found the cheapest hotel that we could
find
um so it was this holiday inn that was
just struggling y'all post covid
i mean it was struggling the room it was
so
hot the ac i swear they actually jack up
the ac at night i think because they
know everyone's going to cool it down
but they want to save money
so the pool we were looking forward to
like hanging out the pool which they had
advertised online we get there
the pool's drained it's just gone we're
just like okay
but honestly 48 hours away it was
amazing
it was great so we had a great time uh
and then we had our family vacation
we went to dangerfield state park in
east texas with my
brother sister-in-law their kids our
kids the whole gang
um and uh yeah so it was just it was
really really great
and actually my brother's here tonight
it's pretty it's pretty rare that josh
is here they don't live close so this is
my bro back here
josh uh he's a good guy you get to meet
him later
so um at any rate yeah it was just great
and and kind of on top of that i mean i
really i think i did pretty good
magazine think like
stepping back not getting like involved
or like obsessively checking email even
when i shouldn't be
i think i did pretty good like stepping
back and you all
there was various leaders and volunteers
and you all just like you just kept
you y'all are capable you did great and
um without missing a beat so i just i'm
really grateful for the
elder team various ministry team leaders
who really stepped up in my absence i'm
just
grateful for y'all so thank you for that
time in space
so um all right we are kicking off
a a new series tonight um
titled deconstruction finding god again
and
i am i'm very excited about this series
it feels
um pretty i don't know just pretty kind
of
relevant timely we'll get more into if
that word is kind of like what on earth
do you talk deconstruction
some of you are totally tracking others
not that's okay
um this message will be kind of a uh an
intro really for the whole series
so by the end of the night you should be
be tracking with me
um so i want to start with a few
scripture readings
uh the first um is from acts chapter
nine and by the way these two passages
they may not seem very related but i
think in their own ways they're kind of
examples of deconstruction which we'll
get into
in a bit so acts chapter 9 verses 1
through 6 says meanwhile saul
um this is the later known as the
apostle paul
but this is kind of the the early years
so saul
was still breathing out murderous
threats
against the lord's disciples he went to
the high priest
and asked him for letters to the
synagogues in damascus
so that if he found any there who
belonged to the way
this was kind of an early way to speak
of christians before the term christian
came about this is how they kind of
talked about this
this strange jewish kind of subset of
judaism that believed the messiah had
come and been crucified and rose again
and
and all that so those who belong to the
way
whether men or women he might take them
as prisoners to jerusalem
as he neared damascus on his journey
suddenly a light from heaven flashed
around him
he fell to the ground heard a voice say
to him
saul saul why do you persecute me
verse 5 who are you lord saul asked
i am jesus whom you are persecuting he
replied
now get up and go into the city and you
will be told what you
must do so that's acts chapter nine
this is a passage this is from matthew
chapter five so this is christ himself
um speaking he says verse 21 you have
heard that it was said to the people
long ago you shall not murder
and anyone who murders will be subject
to judgment
but i tell you that anyone who is angry
with a brother or
sister will be subject to judgment
verse 38 skipping down of ways you have
heard it was said
eye for eye in a tooth for a tooth but i
tell you
do not resist an evil person if anyone
slaps you
on the right cheek turn to them the
other cheek
also so the title of my message tonight
is who's afraid of deconstruction
who's afraid of deconstruction and i
want to begin
with a story so there was um
uh not was there is a young man i knew
this man well
um in his early years i mean he was like
very christian-y uh raised in the church
you know very churchy and uh
when you would ask him uh like when he
was a little kid like seven you know
like hey what do you want to be when you
grow up
uh he would say a missionary that's what
he said i mean that's
pretty churchy um you all agree he's
like
yeah i mean who says that like no it's
supposed to be firefighter i don't know
whatever little kids say
but no it was missionary um he he was uh
kind of born and raised in this like
very it was kind of a little country
church um
you know pretty like conservative and
the uh
the whole thing but it was um but it was
like good like
good community you know people really
loved others there you know not
perfectly but um but pretty well
uh so this kid he grows up he goes off
to bible college
um there he
well this is kind of where essentially
um
strangely enough you think bible college
is the place where your faith is like
reinforced
you're like yes that's what i'm talking
about that's why i believe what i
believe
um but actually for this young man it
was the exact opposite it was a very
jarring experience he found a lot of the
professors um
quite kind of arrogant um not really
kind of expressing the love of christ
very well and so you know like when
you're mentors and the people you're
supposed to be looking up to
are kind of jerks that's like uh
maybe you've been in churches where like
the leaders were like
jerkish you know and that's kind of i
mean everyone has their moments but you
don't want like consistent jerkishness
from your
church leaders you know um so
he's there um and there were a few kind
of key moments
uh that were really difficult so there
was one day where
he uh figured out or kind of learned the
class was on how the bible
came together and he you know
kind of raised the conservative church
like this is like the foundation of the
faith this is the whole game right here
and as he started to learn about how it
all came together it was so
sort of um like almost human
like there were votes like church
leaders kind of like voting and many
people were like i don't know about this
book of hebrews like it's real good
but we don't know who wrote it and i'm
just not sure so it was like some people
voted for that others not
a lot of people had a lot of questions
about the book of revelation just kind
of i don't know
like it would be a nice little capstone
at the end it does kind of sum things up
but on the other hand it's kind of
there's just a lot going on there we're
not sure about
so the whole process i mean it was like
he was just sort of like what is
going on like i don't you know i don't i
don't know about all this
um then you start adding on other things
um thinking about science
learning about you know the theory of
evolution and then how could i reconcile
you know like
how does he how is he gonna kind of make
sense of that with
the creation of genesis one and two and
a literal reading of that
um what else oh how could god
you know order people to slaughter
innocent women and children in the
taking of the promised land
what else there's more oh how could god
torture human beings for all eternity in
a place called hell
the god who is love though you know it's
just sort of like i
i don't know and then add on to that you
know politics so there was like
he was kind of raised in this atmosphere
where you know a certain conservative
bent that's putting it sort of gently um
you know is sort of expected like that's
you know the godly thing and yet he also
heard not only that you know kind of um
political group but even church folks um
i mean just the way they would speak for
example among
other things about people in the lgbtq
community and it was just like ah
he just he couldn't make sense of this
and slowly just sort of
piece by piece brick by brick
his faith it just sort of came apart
it um it was uh
a deconstruction
and uh
my hunch is even if like the details are
different
um either you yourself have gone through
some sort of process like that
again maybe not those exact issues i
mean maybe it was just
um the church you were attending um
exploded
you know a big controversy something you
know something
and it was just like oh my god and it
deconstructed your faith right like the
details could be different
um and if not you probably someone you
know
right maybe a sibling um a son a
daughter a grandchild
um have does this kind of make sense
like is this kind of a somewhat familiar
story is this
yeah yeah so right this is kind of a
thing
um in the culture um
and i you know i was even thinking like
just in the past few years like if
you're all a listener of christian
podcasts
or a reader of christian books um you've
probably
kind of picked up on these ideas this
idea of like deconstruction
some of you may have heard the story of
joshua harris
who back in the 90s he was like sort of
the protestant evangelical golden child
he wrote the book i kiss dating goodbye
does anyone remember this book uh-huh
okay there's a number of you
um if you've joined christian faith or
church
kind of since you know into like the
2000s you may not have heard this book
but if you were in the church world back
then you might have
heard um so he so he writes this but i
just kissed stating goodbye he starts
you know quite um
kind of a uh evangelical sort of
ministry out of this
now fast forward like i don't know 15
years
um and i think this i heard about this
just as i think it was around the time
kovid kind of hits
like a year and a half ago or a year ago
or so um
that it was like a big thing that he
basically publicly threw it it was
instagram or something
basically denounced all of his previous
writings
um he said i've just i've been in you
know for years now this kind of season
of deconstruction
um his marriage came to an end uh
he was and basically announcing that
it wasn't like he was now adopting kind
of a new version of christian faith or
something but he
was he no longer no longer considers
himself a christian
in any way um no affiliation um
and so this is this is
even though he's kind of a somewhat
christian celebrity but this is sort of
sweeping
you know the nation in a way like this
this deconstruction thing
um and if you're kind of scratching your
head like i still i haven't heard about
this
i don't you don't know just um talk chat
with someone like in their early 30s
down to 20s
that's really the window where a lot of
this is like happening everyone's
listening to the liturgists or you know
whoever and like
just working through things so
um i realize um
in a moment i'll define deconstruction
just just so you know but i want to name
that basically what this series is about
is asking okay what is deconstruction um
why can it actually be a good thing and
not something we need to be like freaked
out about
um and what might god have for us in the
midst of it that'll be
um and and i'll be also hitting on a
number of different
kind of topics that often push people
into kind of a phase or a season of
deconstruction
so um it'll be yeah we'll kind of be
trying to cover
cover the gamut so let me give you a
definition deconstruction what is it all
right i'm going to call or just say that
it's the process of realizing
that what i thought was unshakable
unchangeable
undeconstructible truth
was not right um in other words
you might say that what i thought um and
in a faith context cause technically you
could deconstruct other things you could
deconstruct your politics or you know
um but but in a faith context it's often
there were certain things that i thought
like okay this isn't just my
interpretation this is like
the truth this is how it is this is how
you know everyone in christian faith has
always thought of it
and if you don't agree that's because
you're either an idiot
or you're being you know willfully
rebellious
does that make sense so it's like this
is how often people kind of get in a
mode like that
and then what deconstruction shows
is like well actually that thing that
interpretation that idea that you
thought was so
rock solid all of a sudden it starts to
get a little
shaky um have you had this experience
with something of like
that idea i was so committed to that
theology
that you know whatever and all of a
sudden it just starts um
wobbling um
and that now kind of hearing it in that
way you might kind of think like well
that's good though and you would be
right like i actually think this can be
god's grace in our life
but there's a difference between saying
something is good and saying something
is super relaxing
and fun and i think that's the trick
with deconstruction honestly
it's really really hard it's somewhat
painful to go
through because it kind of feels like
the
my whole story about the world
is like crashing down
right that's where it's one thing to
like i don't know
do you construct something smaller you
know some i don't know your like
favorite car
like and i realized that car wasn't as
good as i thought right and this is not
going to be as emotionally
jarring unless you really love cars
maybe but for most people right
but when you start talking about i mean
god
like my whole sort of all my values
why i think things are right or wrong i
mean these are like this is
foundational stuff right and so when
that starts getting shaky oh gosh
oh gosh i was thinking um back on these
passages for example think of the jesus
passage
um where he's doing this basically
you've heard it said
but i say or but i tell you right and
what's what's he doing here
he's basically quoting either a
scripture or kind of a variation of it
and then he's giving a certain
interpretation right so
um for example it's you know you've
heard it said like you shall not murder
and apparently
where people were running with that was
like okay so as long as i don't kill
i'm good i'm hateful i'm resentful
i'm not gonna forgive you know so i'm
bitter but hey i didn't kill anyone
and so what is jesus doing he's like
okay no no we need to
keep thinking like you're obeying the
letter of the law
um you are missing the spirit of the law
right you've heard it said
and you're like well that's what the
bible says he's like yes but i say to
you
can you see how i'm imagining to some
religious folks that was probably a
little bit of an uncomfortable moment
like oh my gosh are you like disagreeing
with the bible what's going on right now
um or what's the other one he does uh
the whole eye for eye tooth for tooth
right this is like and this is like
called justice something bad happens to
you well then whoever did it to you the
same should happen to them
and this is how the world works and he's
like yeah
no when you start moving away from that
and you can see how he's
he's he's starting to to twist to um
to give a new reading a fresh
interpretation and my hunch is for the
people
the listeners maybe for us we're very
familiar perhaps of the passages or
we're like oh you should love or you
know whatever
maybe it's not uncomfortable for us but
at least for the original hearers
this was a somewhat radical thing jesus
was doing um now the other
passage right is um
struggling is this acts 9
text um so this is the the story of the
deconstruction of paul
and i want you to to kind of recognize
what's going on here so here's paul
i mean again he has a whole way of
viewing the world
and he is like on a righteous
path i mean he because there is there
are these heretics
these religious heretics these followers
of the way
and he is committed to god and his
truth and so right can you see how he's
kind of got a story he's got a path he's
got an
idea and is he like wishy-washy
on this um no he's confident real
confident i mean to the point where he's
willing to like be putting people in
prison over this
and suddenly the risen christ is
speaking to him and he's oh my gosh
what now of course we can fast forward
and see like but paul it was so good
man like this was the truth breaking in
in your life how beautiful
it led you on this great path and it was
awesome
and i'm sure looking back he could say
yes two thumbs up
but in the moment as paul is literally
knocked off his high horse and
blinded i mean this
is a moment of deep trauma
like religious trauma of oh my have you
ever had that moment in your life
where you were so confident you were
right like
so confident you knew that you knew that
you knew
and then all of a sudden through a
series of circumstances maybe slowly
through the years whatever it is
but you realize oh my gosh i was so
wrong well y'all what is that moment
like especially if it happens like
quickly
oh gosh maybe if it happens over a few
years you can kind of acclimate slowly
like oh yeah you know i used to believe
some wrong-headed things you can kind of
acclimate but
when it's quick when it's like kicked
off your horse
oh no not fun
but but good
but good um
so let me um kind of segue to why like
why do we need to deconstruct
um i think basically we have to
deconstruct so that we can grow up if
you're a note taker
you can jot this down deconstruction is
a normal process
through which we are able to spiritually
and emotionally
mature um theologian he was actually a
professor of mine
um his name is aj swoboda
and he has a pretty insightful book on
on deconstruction
and one of his ideas um is that
he said think of the way like what
happens in therapy
right whenever you go to therapy and i
don't just mean like christian therapy i
just mean
any sort of therapy right you go and
usually at some point within the first
kind of session or two maybe three
um what does the the counselor or the
therapist what do they ask you
um inevitably they ask you like hey so
tell me about your family
right sort of like talk talk to me tell
me because they're trying to get insight
into who is this person sitting
in front of me and what's informed and
why are they doing that because
whether we realize it or not and this is
often why therapy can be quite
insightful and helpful but also a little
bit shocking
is um because they basically lead you
through a process
of deconstructing your family of origin
right of you have all these inherited
ideas
beliefs this is what's normal
right this is just the way the world
works this is and you
they kind of help you sift through and
start to do this taking inventory
to say okay what here is good
and what from my family of origin was
like
pretty messed up you know not maybe not
so
not not such a winner winner chicken
dinner on that point right
um and we go through this process and so
buddha what he
he names so beautifully is he says
deconstruction in a faith context is
very similar
except instead of it being biological
family what is it
it's your church family and specifically
your church family of origin
so whatever kind of faith community you
were connected to
um and uh and by the way i realized
maybe not everyone
had that exact experience all right of
being in a church or something
although even there you probably still
picked up just by being in the culture
you picked up what certain ideas of
god and truth and right can you see how
this process happens
it's like i'm picking things up um and
this is what happens right in our
kind of church context we pick things up
in the um
i mean just naturally and then
deconstruction is a process
of having to wrestle with okay well i
thought at least when i was little like
everything from that church was just the
truth
and now i'm kind of realizing um that
they were um well it was an imperfect
church
um i i started with that story and as
many of you picked up
uh at the very beginning um that was my
story
i was that little boy and i want to be a
missionary so adorable
little brett um and you know as i look
back on my own
kind of church family of origin it
really was um i mean it was
there was a lot of good there um a lot
of good
um but you know it was still human
beings that ran that church
and um i had to
as i grew up i really had to wrestle
with huh
like maybe those folks weren't just the
mouthpiece of
god to me
um and i look back just to give a few
examples i don't want to like rant and
rave about like oh that church was so
bad because it wasn't that right but
um i do want to give some concrete
examples like for example as i look back
our the way we um kind of treated women
for example
um and even just thought like we had
this very strict kind of
gender role this ideal this sort of
proverbs 31
woman you know whatever that means
exactly this sort of
i just very straight like this is what a
woman is and
um and it was hard for people that
didn't like
fit that mold you know
um and then you add on top of that just
our kind of belief that really it was
sort of men who had to run things and be
in control and
you know lead because um you know i mean
there was i won't go into the theology
it wasn't great
it just it wasn't great that's an
understatement it was real bad
and and that's that was something that
as i grew up into my 20s i just started
to realize like
oh my gosh that was
kind of icky um
of course and uh the other one i alluded
to earlier
was also just the way we kind of spoke
about related to
um gay lesbian transgender folks i mean
it was just
a it was a mess it was real bad
which is and this is what's so kind of
strange about
um deconstructing your own
faith and church theology is like it's
the very people who taught you
like you know the good like how to pray
how to worship how to you know love god
and
you know who christ is it's like all of
the good
and yet it's those exact same people
who also gave you certain things
that as you grow up you realize like oh
my gosh maybe that wasn't from
from christ you know and you know what's
tricky
is it's easy to kind of i don't know do
a little scapegoating of like oh my gosh
can you believe my church you know back
in the day how terrible
um what's interesting is that as kids
grow up here what are they going to do
with the table
right they're going to have to
deconstruct they're going to have to
wrestle they're going to see
um our blind spots
the places where we were off and missed
it
is that a little little humbling you say
that's humbling
it's humble right it's sort of in the
same right if you think of biological
family same process
right we're like oh my gosh my parents
they were so imperfect and then of
course what our kids gonna do
same thing um this is this is the
process
um another pastor writer john comer um
gave i think some some real insight as
well when he named that um
developmental psychologist point out
that when we're forming beliefs
we kind of go through three stages um
stage one
is um called construction right this is
where
you just receive something it's sort of
like me as the little kid in the church
right just my sunday school teacher said
such and such about god and i was like
yep
that's the truth right it's just i just
receive it so whatever about god sin
the world christ myself community i mean
just all the things
right we just sort of receive it and
we're just constructing all the kids
right now in that that room right there
which is why we're very careful
in terms of what we're teaching them in
those rooms um
because we know right they're not at a
place where they're gonna like analyze
this like
little pushback teacher you know like
probably not they're just
they're at the they're at stage one
right they're just constructing
now um my point isn't that construction
is bad you know we're like oh how
immature no no we all do this
we all do this we have to receive
a certain story about the world and live
into it just just how it goes
now the downside or the some of the the
challenge and why we can't stay at stage
one
is because it tends to be
very rigid and very black and white
sort of overly simplistic like we've
ever heard this statement like the bible
says it
i believe it that settles it maybe
you've seen that bumper sticker it's
kind of out there
um the problem with that is it's just
too simple
right two and but this is stage one it's
sort of there everything's very
simple and like that's the truth just
believe it and it has no room
for questions it doesn't have much room
for
doubt oh don't you say the d word in
church
doubt don't right and that stage one
that's the real that's the struggle is
it tends to be very rigid
very black and white not much room for
ambiguity because that's the thing right
the world is complicated
the world is messy and even faith is a
lot of
gray which leads us into stage two a
certain percentage of people
kind of move on to stage two this is
um deconstruction this isn't what we've
been talking about it's the season of
doubt
it's the season of question asking it's
the season
of wrestling it's where you probe and
search and
interrogate um this is also the season
when you are very clear what you are not
can you see that right i am
not fill in the blank i am not a
conservative you think i'm a
conservative i am not
right or i am not a liberal or i am not
baptist i am not pentecostal not anymore
right and it's
it's this sort of season where it's
we're quite reactionary right
and i'm not trying to well i'm poking a
little fun but not too much because i
get it right it's like we're
we're deconstructing something that
probably really needed to be
deconstructed
i mean jesus did it paul had this
experience like we need these moments
but the challenge is um it tends to be
just
sort of a negative season where it's
just you know this is what i'm not about
um and you know what's what's kind of
interesting
um is that if you look at our culture i
don't just mean church culture i mean
like the broader culture because you can
do this with politics as well
right like you're in the season where
you were one political party and then
you make the great switch
and so it's like oh my gosh i am not
that and anyone who is that is
evil and from the devil right and we
kind of get in these modes
um even here's what's interesting even
if you leave kind of faith
like kind of deconstruct and leave um
you can still be kind of stuck in stage
one or stage two
i mean if you've ever been like read
comments on the internet
um you've heard from you know some folks
who don't believe in god
who don't have a lot of room for like
ambiguity
and questions you know like isn't that
interesting no no it's just like
you're an idiot if you believe in god
you know it's sort of it's a very
stage one stage two kind of um
mode of being um which is why i think
it's really important especially in
church
that we pass through the stage of
deconstruction and keep going
and come into stage three this is
what we'll just call reconstruction this
is where i think we start to rediscover
um god in the world and in this context
our christian
faith and we start kind of rebuilding
but it's not the same as going back to
stage one
because um now there's room
can you see the difference now there's
some room for questions
room for doubt room to say things like
i don't know that's something you'll
never hear at stage 1 or stage 2.
i'm not sure um
and just in closing the reason i think
this matters these stages matter and
and i think this series matters for us
as a church is my hunch is that
a lot of other church communities are
probably very tempted to be stage
one communities just much
um what's our temptation stage two
that's that's gonna be the trick for the
table is how
do we go through that and come out the
other side
without going back to stage one and
being rigid and dogmatic and how dare
you disagree with me and you know we
don't want to do that
but how do we keep going because
our mission here at the table is to
shift a generation
from reactionary to visionary
through the person and work of jesus
and you know what that's describing is a
shift from stage two
reactionary what i'm not what i'm
against
which our whole culture is playing that
game we are just stuck
in what we're not what we're not for
right and we shift from reactionary to
visionary this is the the positive step
this is
um where with humility with
grace with room for doubt and questions
i say
um this is who i think god is
and this is who christ is for me and
this is why i want to live the way of
love and this right and you start
articulating a positive vision that's
going to be the trick
for us at the table um
and so really what i want to do is just
invite you i guess on this journey with
us
you know whether this is um whether
you've been with us for a while this is
your first time
i just want to invite you into the
process of moving through these stages
and not in a way to rush you
like well by the end of this series
everyone should be at stage three
you know it's a process everyone there's
grace for wherever we're at
but at least we can kind of start to get
a framework and um
man by just the grace of god i think he
can take us somewhere
that sound good all right let me pray
for you lord jesus
uh i just i thank you for
just every person sitting here
and um no matter where they are on their
faith journey
whether they've been at this a long time
or they feel
really new to anything christian
i pray god that you would meet them
right in the midst of their journey
in fact i want to just invite you if
you'd like just to kind of open up your
hands on your uh
on your lap if you just want to kind of
just as a symbol of
um inviting god to speak to you during
this series
not with some expectations of like a
miraculous moment or something but
but just has it just a symbol just
saying lord i just i want you
to speak to me like maybe you feel very
stuck in stage one
or stuck in stage two and you're wanting
to keep moving if that's you i just want
you to open up your hands and let me
pray for you lord would you
um just do your good work in every
person with your hands open god
may your spirit speak to them
may they sense your presence may truth
happen to them
god even when it's uncomfortable and
difficult
may your truth happen
and god we welcome you into this process
we welcome you into our hearts and minds
over the next
10 or 11 weeks lord would you just may
your kingdom come may your will be done
yeah we love you god in the powerful
name of jesus i pray
amen thanks brett
we are gonna wrap up with a song
from an album that
i would highly encourage you guys to
listen to if you want to stick with us
in the series of deconstruction
um it's by gunger and oh gosh scott is
it one life
they have three phases of this album or
they're three albums that all go
together in a set
i should have really done more research
before i said this he'll look it up and
he'll yell it at us
it's it's really great um but it really
is going through
the process of deconstruction and song
and i've
i've really clung to some of the lyrics
and different songs
um and just i know we're wrapping up and
our kids ministry workers are ready to
get out but just really quickly before
we do the song we're not even going to
have words up on the screen because i
just want you guys to be able to kind of
reflect for a minute
and let brett's message sit with us and
kind of take inventory like what are our
thoughts how is this hitting us
what are we feeling um because that's
important
it's important not to run from our
feelings and there have been times and
you may or may not relate with this
where i hear somebody say different
things that are very offensive to me at
first because they're messing with
what our youth pastor used to call a
sacred cow like this little idol this
perfect little
bronze idol and um you know then
somebody comes down and says you have an
idol over god you know like get rid and
you're like but this is so beautiful and
so gold and wonderful and i just want to
keep this little thing that makes me
feel so good about myself and my faith
and
at first it feels so very offensive and
it's hard to digest it
but then fast forward and there was a
point
in my family with me and josh where
we um had two boys that were stillborn
and someone walked up to me and said
everything happens for a reason and
then i understood that there are things
that
are very good to deconstruct and pull
apart because
a lot of us have bad religion in us
and the name of this song is called let
bad religion die
and and there are things that sometimes
we believe that we don't even realize
are wrong
until we walk through the pain um
you know that we wouldn't have
experienced otherwise we wouldn't have
been able to
pick it apart or tear it apart so if
you're in a place where tonight
something's hitting you and it feels
offensive
let's just take inventory let's see like
why are we feeling that
what what could god be showing us what
could be on the other side
and um or maybe this is all hitting home
for you in a very freeing way like thank
god somebody's finally saying that from
the pulpit you know what i mean like i
have those moments too where it's like
just you know yes please keep saying
more
so wherever you are i just encourage you
to let these words
soak in and let's embrace a better
religion together and let's be um
slow to take up a fence and quick to
listen to the spirit of god and what he
is doing inside of us in our hearts you
know and let him
sometimes get rid of our sacred cows get
rid of our little golden idols that
we've made
of you know whatever religious history
we have
so that's my quick long story before we
go into this song sorry
that album's called one wild life one
wild life
thank you bye gunger g-u-n-g-o-r
[Music]
with the bomb strapped to his chest
with a bullhorn in her hand
they both bow their head and pray
to do god's will fulfill the faith
and walk into the crowd
[Music]
if all the outsiders are wrong
and if your questions don't be long
and if your doubt is called a sin
and you're not to search within
let it go open your eyes
[Music]
die all
believe demanding blood
if your god gives you a gun
[Music]
if it spreads violence more than peace
god let religion cease
a million lies for jesus christ
they spread the word with genesis
[Music]
their crusades were meant to save
but who's this god that hates and hates
and what's this love that draws the line
[Music]
let them
their authority is a lie
you are free and you'll be fine
let their religion die
[Music]
if it spreads violence more than peace
god let religion see
[Music]
thanks mindy in the band thank you guys
for being with us tonight and those of
you online for joining us
we hope that every part of this service
drew you to christ in some way
for those of you that might be in need
of prayer i'll stay up here
after the service i would be more than
happy to pray with you or just listen to
you
if you're wanting that also if you're
visiting with us tonight whether in here
or online we would love to stay in touch
with you
for those of you in here we have cards
on the table right before you leave the
the door
please fill that out put it in the box
and we'll be sure to get in contact with
you
for those online you can use our comment
form which i believe
james is going to link to on the live
stream
and then also if you'd like to give
financially to the table you can do that
online
or the box in the back and
also please don't forget we're gonna go
have dinner after this it's a great time
for community
at hack creek burger company here in
saxi
and finally if you all would stand
if you're able i would like to send you
off with this benediction
you are a child of god
this is true on your best days and on
your worst days
it's true for those that are standing
around you or sitting next to you right
now
and it's also true for others that are
outside of this building outside of
christianity
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between go
with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend those same
gifts of unconditional love and grace
to everyone you come in contact with
this week be blessed and we hope to see
you back here next sunday
good night
[Music]
you